this morning more pressure on prince
andrew as an american judge rules he
must be questioned under oath by
virginia dufrese lawyers by the middle
of july next year could it clash with
the queen's platinum jubilee
celebrations in june
plus another day another handout now
it's public sector workers in line for a
pay rise we'll ask the business minister
paul scully about that and how it's
going to be funded uh in just a few
moments time also ahead all for one
we'll meet the mom who decided a tattoo
was better than reconstructive surgery
after a mastectomy and now her daughters
are supporting her with the same design
there you go in addition to that
[Music]
as you've never seen her before relaxed
laughing and loving the limelight at the
climate live gig we'll meet the
organizer who's putting on similar
concerts right around the world it's
tuesday the 26th of october
a us judge rules prince andrew must be
questioned under oath
in the virginia du frey sexual assault
case by mid-july next year
ending the freeze more than 5 million
public sector workers are in line for a
pay increase in the latest giveaway
revealed by the chancellor rishi sunak
they need to say we're going to pay
public sector of staff and all workers
in the economy a decent wage next year
good morning from heathrow where the
latest figures show just how much air
traffic has picked up in the third
quarter
an abuse of power a big rise in the
number of police officers flighting
their position for sexual purposes as a
victim tells us action is overdue
if they break the law then surely there
should be you know absolute zero
tolerance policy far too many police
officers
that have done something wrong you know
it's all swept under the carpet
dirty data how unwanted digital photos
are clogging up storage sites and
causing hundreds of tons of carbon
emissions
[Music]
overnight a judge in the united states
has ruled that prince andrew must answer
questions under oath by the middle of
july next year in the sexual assault
case being brought against him by
virginia dufresne
the duke of york will need to be
available to give evidence in the civil
case by the 14th of july in an order
agreed to by his uh and also mr frey's
lawyers she alleges that the prince
forced her to have sex with him on more
than one occasion including around 20
years ago at the london home of gillane
maxwell an associate of the late sex
offender jeffrey epstein there's a
chance any questioning could clash with
the queen's platinum jubilee
celebrations taking place next june
prince andrew has not been charged with
a crime and denies any wrongdoing we'll
be speaking to the legal expert joshua
rosenberg in just a few moments time
also still to come on the program for
you 7 30 we are joined by dr david
navarro from the world health
organization to examine the global
handling of the kovid 19 crisis
do the police have a sexual abuse
problem we'll be asking the former
deputy assistant commissioner at the met
stephen roberts as new figures reveal a
sharp rise in officers and staff facing
action for sex abuse allegations
we'll be getting the thoughts from the
shadow chief secretary to the treasury
james murray on government plans to
increase public sector pay that's at
five past eight
also this morning
another day another announcement and
it's still not even budget day yet
millions of public sector workers are in
line for a pay increase as the
chancellor rishi sunak confirms he's
scrapping the year-long pay freeze
public sector average weekly earnings
rose by four and a half percent in the
financial year to april pay increases
for the sector were frozen for 21 22
with the exception of the nhs and
workers earning less than 24 000 pounds
there are almost 5.7 million public
sector workers in the uk who will now be
hoping for a pay rise
we've spoken to a range of people about
this during our great debate program
last night to those struggling to manage
and to the union representing public
sector workers
the government needs to make a
commitment not just some vague
statements in the budget they need to
say we're going to pay public sector
staff and also all workers in the
economy a decent wage next year
recognize that this has been a tough 18
months
and that therefore we want to boost the
economy we want that high wage we want
that high productivity economy and we
want to ensure that public sector
workers are part of that process
let's say
who
amongst our viewers panel think that it
is right and we can afford that 6.6
increase can i see those in who think
it is right and we should afford it well
we're pretty clear
we think he can
and we should
more on that to come with the minister
very shortly but first the number of
police officers and staff being
disciplined after abusing their position
for sexual purposes has risen sharply in
the last three years it comes as the
fallout from the murder of sarah everard
at the hands of a serving police officer
continues emma burchie reports
the horror of sarah everard's final
hours prompted an outpouring of grief
but it was the fact that the man
responsible was a serving police officer
which added to the disbelief at her fate
wayne cousins pretended to be on duty
when he kidnapped the 33 year old before
raping and then murdering her earlier
this year
his case is extreme but he's not alone
in abusing a position of trust for
sexual gain
and the number of cases being reported
has soared
the abuse of position for a sexual
purpose currently makes up nearly 60
percent of investigations by the
independent office for police conduct
from 2018 to 2021 66 officers and
members of police staff faced
disciplinary proceedings as a result
42 of those in the past year
in 63 cases misconduct was proven
with six people convicted of crimes
those figures have gone up because it's
become a mandatory referral so people
have to refer it to us now but we would
hope that also it reflects a increased
awareness
where we are seeing fellow officers for
example reporting people that they
believe might be doing that and those
are being referred to us as well
it hasn't reassured former animal rights
activist jessica who was unaware her
partner of a year back in the 90s was an
undercover officer if they break the law
then surely there should be you know
absolute zero
tolerance policy
and you know it needs again it's that
it's the transparency you know far too
many police officers
that have done something wrong you know
it's all swept under the carpet you know
there's the the sort of the policy of
you know the old boys club
the organizers of the vigil held after
sarah everard's murder also want more to
be done
if we are only measuring instances of
harassment and violence we're missing
all of the warning signs of misogyny
this report uh from the iopc talks about
um
sexual offenses uh where an officer
abuses their power well that's the worst
case scenario before that point that
officer has probably
done things which make women
uncomfortable when cousin's nickname was
the rapist the iopc is clear that those
who abuse their position for sexual gain
will be found out
but there's work to be done to rebuild
trust in those whose roles should be to
protect
emma birchley sky news
let's talk about uh public sector pay
should we um and the minimum wage ahead
of the budget
tomorrow um hello paul scully is here
with us the business minister hello to
you thanks for joining us on the program
it's always great to see you um rishi
sunix said oh last november i think i'm
writing saying that he couldn't justify
a public sector pay increase what has
changed in the last 12 months i think
we've um you know it's given us the gap
to uh allow for public sector finances
to or public finances to be looked at in
the in the hole now we've got a better
picture of where we are in terms of the
recovery having put 352 billion pounds
worth of uh support into protecting jobs
and livelihoods he now has a that better
picture to look forward and make sure
that
having had the public set to pay gone up
previously
ahead of private sector pay it started
to equalize and now he can give all of
us public sector workers who do an
amazing job at pay rise how much well
that will be determined by the pay
review body so we each um the nurses
have their pay review bodies police etc
they each have their individual pay
review
bodies who will report back to him but i
think what it does take notice of those
do you well it gives them it gives them
a signal it gives them a signal that the
chance to know is uh you know is keen to
give people rise so they will then take
that into account as they look for um to
what um should be an appropriate rise
for public sector
given the public finances as well they
can report back in the challenge you
don't always take notice of what they
say do you we we tend to we try to
we try to but
it's a it's a review body we look to to
that to them to provide us evidence and
then we'll make our decision but we tend
to keep as aligned as possible but as i
say the chancellor has signaled that
very clearly and so when we will look
favorably when the pay review bodies are
reported make sure we get that paid rise
let's look at it in a different way then
inflation could hit four percent this
year so they're going to get at least
that
i think it's well i can't tell you
because as i say that's exactly
otherwise it's a pagan well that's
that's what the paper review bodies will
do i mean i can't preempt what they're
going to do i can't pretend what the
chancellor is going to say said now is
the time to give them a pay rise
and inflation could hit 4 so unless it's
more than four percent it's a pay cut
well i think as i say we will see where
we are uh come next april when the
review bodies have
paid what we've done though in the uh
reported what we've done in the um just
yesterday the chancellor and the
treasury were announcing the national
living wage increase of 6.6 percent uh
so i think that is a a generous but
balanced approach to the lowest paid in
out um in our society to to make sure
that businesses can still recover
balance but it doesn't come anywhere
near uh the cuts uh in universal credit
of a thousand pounds it's a gross
increase of a thousand pounds a year and
what and
what we're doing is six percent six
would that depends on the circumstance
of the person well
ifs paul johnson director of says it's
about 250 quid it depends on how many
hours those people are working so it's
it's you know he's made he's made one
assumption he's made one assumption but
but it will literally depend on some
people maybe part-time on that some
people full time something and how many
hours some people it'll be 250.
nonetheless it's uh it's what you've got
to look at six point six percent is
something that that
it continues our um reach to making sure
that the national living wage by 2024 is
two-thirds of um of average median wage
so ending low pay but not stifling the
growth and the recovery of businesses
that are paying that living wage because
we want to make sure as i said we can
balance it between employers um and
those workers that really need that
money you're talking about um businesses
let's look at business rates then um
should we where are we as far as that is
concerned tinkering around the edges
again is is what uh i read an article
this morning in business leader saying
um that
10 15 000 um
outlets have uh gone and uh tens of
thousands of jobs have been lost
directly as a result of you not sorting
out business rates i'm not sure whether
tinkering around comes though you have
to wait for the fundamental business
rates review which has been taken to be
taken into account
four times already well it's due to
report this all this autumn um
is again it sits with treasury so we'll
see what the chancellor says on
wednesday if he
has any indication about that but i'm
the hospitality minister and the retail
minister so clearly i hear from those
businesses who are on the high street
who are most affected by business rates
about their concerns which are
reflective to treasury but others say
the word is fundamental we do know that
uh business rates needs to uh adapt to
the 21st century to make sure that we
get the balance right between high
street um bricks and mortar and online
online shops and that will be taken okay
so just to clarify um it's been battered
away four times you still can't tell me
whether it's going to be looked at this
autumn
inflation is going to be 4 but you can't
tell me whether a pay rise is going to
be more than that for public sector
workers and as far as universal credit
is concerned that was a thousand pounds
that's been cut and some people might
only get 250
despite the national living wage is that
what we're saying well look let's take
that last one the universe could go out
okay finally i can go through all of
them you know pay review as as i said
the bodies need to report before we
before we um uh but it could be a packer
you acknowledge that it could be a pain
it could be anything
well it could be anything we need to see
what the pay review bodies say what it
could literally literally couldn't be
it's the pay review bodies four percent
what inflation is going to be unless
it's higher than four percent is going
to be first first of all you're making
the assumption about inflation let's see
where we get to that event you're also
then making up needs to be higher than
four we're also making a review
we'll also make an assumption on what
pay review bodies to say let's see what
the pay reviews bodies are say but what
the chancellor has done he's indicated
that he wants to make sure that he can
give but unless
then the rate of inflation can pay cuts
he's going to end the phrase i'm not
very good at maths but i figured that
one out
yeah but you're but this is all
speculation what i'm saying is that okay
let's not say four percent then let's
say whatever the rate of inflation is
unless the pay review body comes in with
higher it's going to be a pay cut isn't
it so well that's just basic math but
we'll let's see but let's look at let's
just see what the pay review box okay
let's talk again about the national
living wage then because um as i said
the director of the ifs paul johnson
says that to some people uh the new
figures will mean that they're taking
home an extra 250 pounds um and they're
losing a thousand pounds with universal
credit so that's also a pay cut but you
are again first of all you're only
taking one thing there because for the
people that are i talked about the fact
that 200 pounds depends on
what the 250 pounds depends on what
their
circumstances are how many hours there
will be you acknowledge that some people
will be impressed but then on top of
that for the lowest paid we have the
household
fund that was announced by the
chancellor that um uh that is uh being
delivered by local authorities to those
most that need we have the energy price
cap we have the increased uh free child
care allowances that we've built up over
the last uh the last few years all of
these things uh have a suite of measures
to help the people most in need so just
taking that one emergency uh measure the
universal um uh uplift that that's
that came to the end or as the emergency
started
to recede um well it's reversed
basically but nonetheless as i say that
was then replaced by a 500 million pound
household fund to target it to targeted
at those most in need because we've
talked about the fact that the so you're
saying that people are going to be
better off next year what i'm saying
what i'm saying is
what i'm saying is that we are
increasing but for the most vulnerable
the lowest paid in society
their living wage by 6.6 what we don't
want to do is build a recovery based on
the backs of those people uh that are
lowest paid in our society so getting
that balance right to make sure that we
don't stifle the recovery by um by
choking um uh business are you saying
people are going to be better off next
year what i'm saying is that they're
going to get six point six percent
well i can't make those assumptions in
terms of
um inflation and other costs at this at
this moment in time what i am going to
say is that pay packets are going to go
up by six point percent six percent if
they're on the national living wage at
the moment okay um the uh
the leader of the house of commons um
the speaker i should say uh very cross
with the chancellor saying what about
all these leaks in the budget why am i
not hearing about this in the chamber
for the first time tomorrow yeah well
i'm sure the the the chancellor will
answer that but i think it's important
that we um that people know these uh
these um concerns have chance to digest
them to debate them to
um to talk about them um over the last
few days as they clearly have you're
casting out for people's opinion
no i'm just i think it says no because
you know the announcement's there
the announcement's been made what i'm
saying is that um you know i think it's
important for people like yourself to
actually be able to discuss that with me
this is where we're going to do it
well i'm not the chancellor so i don't
know it's the honest answer do you think
it's a good idea i'm just telling i
think having the discussion about these
sort of things making sure that um the
people on the national living wage for
example don't miss out on seeing some of
the detail because it's lost in a
massive budget document i'm sure they
don't know if they're struggling with
the playback absolutely are they i'm
sure they're able to i'm sure
they will also see some of the other
things they will see some of the other
things that are available to them as
well that sometimes get lost will you be
wearing a mask for the budget
uh i'm not sure if i'm in the chamber
for the budget if you are but i thought
it depends on how crowded it is it's
gonna be packed yeah in that in that
case which my wire might not be in the
chamber because i've been off and if you
are and it's packed if it's absolutely
where i have been in a um
a room or an area where it has been
absolutely rammed then i wear a mask i
wear a mask in the cab on the way here i
wear a mask on the tube on the trains
because all your colleagues don't tend
to or many of you colleagues don't tend
to do they i think the signal look the
signal is for people to um you know
we've been locked down for 18 months and
the government have been telling people
what to do for 18 months what we have
said to people now use your common sense
use your own initiatives make your own
informed decisions we know that we're
living with covid
and so this doesn't just suddenly go
away overnight so it's really important
that we allow people to make those make
those informed decisions and be
respectful for other people as well
around them it's going to be look a bit
weird isn't it when all the labour
benches have all got their masks on and
lots of the tory benches don't
sending a mixed message isn't it to the
public as usual i think that i think the
message is that as i say make your
decisions for yourselves okay but you
access accept that it's mixed messages
if half the house has got masks on the
other look it depends where you want to
go to if you want the government to be
dictating to you every minute of the day
that's one thing is it a mixed message
it's it's a message that you can use
your own
you use your own initiative use your own
make your own decisions good to talk to
you thanks so much indeed for joining us
on the program thank you and a reminder
we'll have live coverage of the budget
here on sky news uh tomorrow of course
and just a reminder if you want to catch
up on any of that interview or watch the
program when you are out and about this
morning then you can absolutely do that
as well online uh the mobile app you can
go to our website as well and go into
our live blog to watch the programme and
you can catch up on the interviews on my
twitter as well if you would like to
that's at k burley
in other news the judge in the united
states has ruled that prince andrew must
answer questions under oath by the
middle of july next year in the sexual
assault case being brought against him
by virginia dufrey prince andrew has not
been charged with a crime and denies all
wrongdoing so what is going on this time
the legal commentator joshua rosenberg
is with us hi joshua thanks for joining
us on the program this morning
what what's happened this time this news
is broken overnight where does this
leave prince andrew this morning
this turns out to be an agreed schedule
agreed between the lawyers for prince
andrew and virginia giffrey and the
district judge in manhattan lewis kaplan
has set the deadline to complete the
written evidence which both sides are
apparently going to give these are
called depositions this is evidence
given under oath but not in court
usually in a lawyer's
office with the other side's lawyers
present and so what the judge is doing
is making it clear this can't drift on
uh he's not prepared to leave it up to
the parties to decide how long this
should take
there has to be a a a fixed point by
which the evidence needs to be in but
he's been pretty generous it's well over
six months so plenty of time
for uh both sides to give their evidence
if that's what they're going to do
um okay so
it could we could find ourselves he
could find himself in a position where
he's having to face
these um
allegations via the lawyers very close
to the queen's jubilee celebrations will
you find ourselves in that position
that is certainly
the concern that's been expressed this
morning but there's no reason why this
has to go up to the wire if prince
andrew is going to give evidence he can
do so at any reasonable time between now
and the middle of next july and even if
it was to be next july it wouldn't
necessarily be public as i say this is
evidence behind closed doors it's not a
court hearing
you've really got three choices if
you're in prince andrew's position
you can first of all ignore the whole
proceedings well he's clearly not going
to do that if you ignore it then the
judge will find against you and then
there's a question of how
a damages award in favor of virginia
jeff ray could be enforced again against
prince andrew well that's not going to
happen
clearly
the other possibility is to fight it and
we don't know whether he's going to do
that and the third possibility is to
settle and all these uh options are open
to him we don't yet know how he's going
to handle this let's talk about
suggesting that virginia giffrey
had promised that she wouldn't sue
anybody else she'd reach the settlement
with other people we don't know the
details of that uh what we do know is
that the case is being proceeded with
and we may not hear for quite some time
uh whether it's actually going to fight
or be settled
okay so just give us the setting of how
he's actually going to have this chat
the idea is and this is something which
is
used
readily in the united states not so much
in the united kingdom is that
you go into a lawyer's office now i'm
not suggesting that prince andrew would
necessarily go to the united states to
do this arrangements could no doubt be
made for it to be done in the united
kingdom if he's willing to to do so uh
he could say i've got nothing to say and
therefore there's no point or he could
just send in a written statement if he
wants to fight this well obviously
it helps him if he gives evidence and
he's he makes himself available for
questioning by virginia jeffrey's
lawyers
so
he would simply be asked questions by a
lawyer the proceedings would be video
recorded they'd be transcribed they'd be
used in evidence when the case finally
comes to court if it's not settled in
the meantime
okay um fascinating stuff joshua thanks
so much indeed for explaining that to us
always appreciate it thank you
in other news australia has pledged to
reach net zero emissions by 2050. the
prime minister scott morrison said he
would take the commitment into
discussions at the cop 26 climate summit
in glasgow which kicks off this weekend
we know we can't let the changes that
are happening around the world just
happen to australia
we know we can't pretend it's not
happening no changes that are occurring
around the world just as we haven't been
pretending in the actions that both the
government has been taking and most
importantly australians have been taking
looking at the impact of climate change
on the planet here is our climate
dashboard for you uh 46
of uh real-time power at the moment is
fossil fuels uh below that you can see
global warming since 1880 at 1.23
degrees um according to some the time
left two stoppers reaching one and a
half degrees celsius above those 1880
figures is 11 years and you can see the
bottom figure the scary figure at the
bottom that is total carbon dioxide
emissions in millions of tons
and a reminder that you can get all the
latest stories about climate change on
the sky news daily climate show which
airs every weekday
evening at 6 30 pm
the metropolitan police commissioner has
apologized to the family of two murdered
sisters for the way it handled their
missing persons report it follows an
investigation by the independent office
for police conduct which find the police
response to the disappearance of nicole
smallman and bieber henry was
unacceptable
in a statement the commissioner dame
crested a dick says while we now know
that very sadly nicola and bibar had
been murdered in the early hours of
saturday the 6th of june 2020 before
they were reported missing if we had
been responding better we may have saved
their friends and family immeasurable
pain
police and emergency services are
attending the scene uh at the home
office after protesters from animal
rebellion scaled the department for
environment food and rural affairs
building in westminster next to the home
office the group which is an offshoot of
extinction rebellion is demanding
government support for a plant-based
food system at cop26
founder of facebook mark zuckerberg has
defended his company after strong
criticism from a former worker who's
accused the social media giant of making
online hate worse francis hogan warned
of more violent unrest like the capitol
hill riots if the facebook algorithms
continue to push divisive content mr
zuckerberg said the company had to
balance difficult social values
britney spears has accused her family of
hurting her deeper than you will ever
know posting on instagram she said she
had been let down by those close to her
and that she'll fight for justice even
if her conservatorship comes to an end
the pop star's life and career have been
controlled by the legal arrangements
since 2008.
heathrow's traffic figures for the third
quarter of this year have just been
released covering the period when more
travel restrictions
were eased what do they say let's find
out i should stand by heathrow 4s hi
aisha what are they saying
morning kay well we definitely have some
positive figures on our hands here the
data shows that in the third quarter
heathrow experienced its first full
quarter of passenger growth since 2019
passenger numbers recovered to 28
of pre-pandemic levels and that really
just highlights how much pent-up demand
there was because that third quarter of
course covers the
summer period people heading out on
summer holidays when we did see those
restrictions these uh restrictions
easing with people who were fully
vaccinated no vaccinated no longer
having to isolate when returning from
ambulance countries and also there were
simplifications to the tests needed as
well
so it really just does highlight how
much demand there was but how much
restrictions were standing in the way
but there is still a very long way to go
heathrow say they don't expect air
traffic to fully recover until 2026
their chief executive john holland k
said that
they are very much on the cusp of a
recovery uh but like i said a long way
to go in total they've lost so far 3.4
billion pounds as a result of the
pandemic okay aisha thanks very much
indeed for the update and speaking to
john holland kay who is the chief exec
of heathrow um very shortly here on the
programme uh quick look at the weather
for you now
in for a pretty mild few days with
showers or more prolonged rain running
in on a west to south westerly wind
now take a look at this a man who likes
to make a statement an italian land
artist has unveiled his latest piece
dedicated to the cop
26 climate summit impressive huh
the giant art piece was created on a 26
000 square meter plot of land near
verona with a tractor plough
and rotating harrow apparently without
the use of any tracing on the ground
most impressive the artist says our
world is the most beautiful art form we
have and it's worth fighting to make it
a better place for all
coming up we're joined by dr david
nabarro from the world health
organization looking at the next stages
of the pandemic that to come
[Music]
now the business minister has refused to
say whether public sector workers are
likely to be better off when their pay
settlement is decided millions of
workers including police officers
teachers and the armed forces are in
line for a pay increase with the
chancellor rishi sunak confirming he's
scrapping the year-long pay freeze pay
bodies will recommend an increase but
the decision on any pay rise will rest
with the government
the pay review as as i said the bodies
need to report before we before we um uh
but it could be a pay cut you
acknowledge that it could be a payment
it could be anything we need to save it
could be anything we need to see what
the pay review bodies say what it could
literally literally couldn't be it's the
pay review bodies four percent what
inflation is going to be unless it's
higher than four percent it's going to
be first of all first of all you're
making the assumption about inflation
let's see where we get to that event
they're making up needs to be higher
than four we're also making a review
we also make an assumption on what pay
review bodies to say let's see what the
pay reviews bodies are say but what the
chancellor has done he's indicated that
he wants to make sure that he can give
but unless
the rate of inflation is
i'm not very good at maths but i figured
that one no yeah but you're but this is
all speculation what i'm saying is that
okay let's not say four percent then
let's say whatever the rate of inflation
is unless the pay review body comes in
with higher it's going to be a pay cut
isn't it so well that's just basic math
but we'll let's see but as long as
you've got it
it's just basic math tomorrow it is kay
um two big announcements yesterday that
he was on to talk about first one is on
the national living wage that's the
minimum wage if you're aged over 23
going up to 9 50 an hour from next year
and the second one is about the public
sector doctors teachers nurses soldiers
they're all going to get a pay rise we
don't know how much yet because how it
works is that the pay review bodies have
to have a look at it over a period of
several months and the government have
to make the final decision and that's
going to happen next april as well but
good news for those 5.7 million public
sector workers but of course the
question is how much of it is going to
get eaten up by tax rises by the rising
cost of living
by inflation and by obviously people who
are on universal credit are going to see
some of that cut back and it's
interesting that the minister couldn't
say whether people would end up being
better off now i have to say it's not a
surprise that the public sector are
going to get a pay rise it was their pay
was frozen last year controversially
because they were told by the chancellor
look people in the private sector are
losing their jobs now in the private
sector things are looking a lot better
the chancellor says the recovery is now
on track so this is not a surprise
they're going to get a pay rise the
question of course is how much will it
be he was right to say it depends how
many hours you do what benefits you're
on and so on but we're hearing that with
everything taken into account it looks
like people on the minimum wage will be
about 250 pounds better off okay for now
um tomorrow thanks tomorrow's take at
nine o'clock looking forward to it
already thank you
could wealthier countries be the ones to
suffer from global vaccine inequality at
a virtual institute for government event
dr david nabarro friend of the program
also of the world health organization
said the virus is a global challenge to
keep out variants that could compromise
the efficacy of the vaccine and he joins
us now hello to you thank you for
joining us on the program this morning i
suppose the message is nobody's safe
unless we're all safe absolutely and
everyone matters when it comes to
pandemics just saying we'll look after
the people inside our own country and
not worry about the others
will come back and hurt us all later so
i'm really really
pleased that you picked up that
discussion we had yesterday there are
big big summits coming up there's the
g20 this weekend and of course there's
the climate event taking place in
glasgow in the next couple of weeks i
really hope that world leaders come out
of this position of seeing responding to
the pandemic as primarily my country my
people and we start to look at it as a
world challenge otherwise the the future
looks
a little bit bleaker than it should be
and that's why i'm pushing so hard okay
so what should the uk be doing with
their excess vaccines
well firstly
we have a global scheme we set it up
last year it's working really well it's
just absolutely dry in terms of vaccines
so if any country has spares give them
to kovacs the world distribution system
and give them early don't give them
three weeks or four weeks before they
expire because it creates incredible
problems secondly just defer defer defer
it you know
don't receive your vaccines for for two
months and let the supplies go to poor
countries and then start receiving them
again it's not going to have big big
problems may postpone booster rollout
very slightly but the real thing is we
just can't go on having rich countries
creaming off the vaccine supply and
stocking it in their own vaults and then
poor countries just have people dying
dying and dying and that's why we're
really pushing this very strongly right
now
that's why i was asking you about kovacs
of course we've many of us have heard of
that already um and the uk said they
were going to send tens and tens and
tens of millions i think we're about
seven percent of what we promised at the
moment um letting the side down
well i think so you know if we're going
to actually help the world get itself
sorted on this pandemic we've got to
have fair shares for everyone and that's
the right way to deal with a pandemic
the virus goes on changing and if you
don't get everybody working on it
simultaneously
all sorts of nasty surprises that could
happen but that means acting now it
doesn't mean saying well we'll get we'll
share the vaccines but we'll share them
next year so everybody just you promise
to do it do it now don't let the side
down okay you're absolutely right
um how are you feeling about mandatory
vaccines for health care staff
my own view is that if you have to
mandate
people to get vaccinated that that means
that there's a breakdown in in shared
understanding and trust i'm really
working hard everywhere to see if we can
get
health workers and other essential
workers agreeing to be vaccinated
without it being a compulsion i i worry
that if you start to compel then that
will provoke a reaction that's nothing
to do with the vaccine nothing to do
with the pandemic but to do with
people's frustration at being instructed
to to do it and otherwise they lose
their jobs so if at all possible i say
to everybody do it by agreement not by
coercion
that's a slight dodge there doctor i'm
going to have to come back to you on
that one what if they don't i know
well
you know i i my own view is that it's
really really difficult if people are
forced to accept something uh done to
their bodies in order to stay in a job
this is my personal view it's been my
view all my life
and so you're asking me and i'm giving
you that personal view
there is no who position on mandatory
vaccines it's up to each individual
government and employer to work out how
to do it but in summary i'm going to say
to you i'm going to say to everybody
who's with us today we don't deal with
this pandemic properly unless we can do
it in partnership the virus is the
problem people are the solution and
everything we can possibly do to get
everyone on side so that we're all
dealing with it together that's what i'm
after and that's why i keep going with
my dodges and answers to your questions
the six months from the second booster
to
the second vaccination to the booster
should that be reduced to five
i don't want again to give a
recommendation on the timing of that one
all i'm saying is boosters aren't going
to be important for people who don't
have strong immune systems but at the
same time there's no absolute hard and
fast rule for when the boosters should
be given but we do need to have booster
programs being set up where there is
vaccine available for those people who
are most in need
especially those as i say whose immune
systems are not working or people who
are older or people who've got other
conditions that put them a particular
stress
okay tomorrow is the budget here in the
united kingdom and the house of commons
chamber will be absolutely chock-a-block
um it does look as though half of the
chamber i'm not going to say politically
half the chamber will be wearing masks
the other half will not which side would
you be on
well everybody can i just tell you
something about this virus it is
absolutely unstoppable it gets
everywhere and so we have to do
everything we possibly can to stop it
and one of the best ways to stop it is a
well-fitting surgical mask properly over
your face
pushed in over your nose covering
everything and that reduces the risk to
others and the risk to you well if it
works why on earth don't people use it
it's not a party political issue this
virus doesn't vote and indeed there's no
difference in how you deal with the
virus whether you vote for this party or
that party so everybody wear masks when
you are in close confinement it's the
right sensible proper thing to do and
everybody should be doing it including
our leaders
and what about jabs for 12 to 15 year
olds where are we on that
well i think that more and more
countries are realizing that if they're
going to go for a vaccine roll out they
will also have to vaccinate children
some countries are vaccinating very
young children all i want to say is if
you're going to vaccinate children uh
it's fine to do that do it in
consultation but please remember by
trying to increase the coverage of
vaccines in in wealthy countries
you are also running the risk of
depriving poorer countries and therefore
the overall response gets a bit
diminished time saying to everybody as
you involve children please also
remember there is the everyone matters
issue got to go on sharing vaccines
widely as well
we are out of time but of course i'm not
going to let you go until you tell me
how the grandchildren are
well so they are absolutely fabulous and
they tune in and they watch uk and otto
who is the one everybody who was born
during lockdown and is now a well as a
thriving one plus year old i sometimes
think that he will grow up remembering
that kate burley is the source of all
good things thank you very much
also your granddad's on the telly hello
good morning
nice to see you thanks for joining us
doctor thank you
thanks kay have a lovely day
thank you
now it's being called dirty data and it
might force the nation's selfie takers
to rethink their habits new research
suggests unwanted digital photos produce
the same amount of carbon emissions as
more than a hundred thousand return
flights from london to australia fraser
moored has more
[Music]
a picture may paint a thousand words but
it might also be contributing to the
climate crisis
a new survey is calling us out of what
it calls our dirty data habits storing
millions of unnecessary photos and
videos on servers around the world
creating a carbon footprint as big as
the airline industries
you don't tend to think about photos and
data
having that much of an impact on
your carbon footprint you tend to think
of aviation you tend to think of
transport social snapping contributes to
350 000 tons of co2 so put that into
perspective that's a lot of data that's
contributing to a lot of co2
rosia kotcher is what you might call a
heavy user as an online sustainable
fashion advocate she takes thousands of
photos but unlike many of us she's well
aware of their potential impact
i take a lot of pictures just to share
online how easy it is to sort of make a
transition from fast fashion to slow
fashion and that means i'm taking
hundreds of pictures of hundreds of
outfits every day i keep a lot of things
on my hard drive anyway and i think i'm
definitely going to do a move like move
my content creation onto hard drives as
much as i can instead of keeping it
in the icloud
the report assumes that the average uk
adult takes almost 900 photos a year the
duplicated and unwanted images left in
storage accumulate over 10 and a half
kilos of co2 emissions per person every
year the equivalent of over 112 000
return flights from london to australia
so are these happy snappers in york
aware of the potential damage their
digital memories might be causing
it's probably something so easy to to
delete all your pictures but it's just
something you you keep them all it's
just have it it does have an impact uh
how much of an impact i'm not sure today
she can't use her phone because it's
full so she has to use my phone i've
just been searching through i've got a
photo of my brother standing over there
and it's taken me 10 minutes to find it
on my phone so yeah there's so many
so yeah i need to get rid of a few
and the way to do that is to delete
duplicates regularly clear out your
cloud storage delete old messages and
emails and whenever possible simply turn
your data hungry devices off
fraser moored sky news
york
now the number of police officers and
staff being disciplined after abusing
their position for sexual purposes has
risen sharply in the last three years it
comes as the fallout from the murder of
sarah everard at the hands of a serving
police officer continues let's speak to
the former deputy assistant commissioner
at the met and that is um stephen
roberts it's good to see you again
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning um
talk to us in a bit more detail if you
would uh please about what you think the
public and um
in particular women i suppose would make
of some of the figures that we're
looking at today
i think what these figures demonstrate
is that the police service and and its
independent watchdog take this sort of
shameful behavior
as seriously as as the public have a
right to expect
in many ways i would be far more
concerned if there weren't a rise
in these sorts of prosecutions
and if there weren't significant figures
because that would mean that nobody was
looking but nobody was dealing with a
problem
it's so easy for a large organization
to put reputational damage ahead of
making sure that its members
uh
apply
proper standards of behavior
we've seen how badly that can go wrong
with
with the police service itself with the
catholic church with all sorts of
professions
what this is
is actually
odd as it may seem it's good news it's
showing that this is being taken as
seriously as it should be
you say that but looking if you sort of
burrow down into these figures a bit
more of the 52 staff who face gross
misconduct proceedings in in the period
that we're talking about
um three out of four of them are no
longer serving but one in four of them
38 are still serving officers and they
face gross misconduct proceedings that
can't be right
well we don't know what the facts of
that particular case were
if they are in the report i haven't had
the chance to read them yet um but you
must remember that it's not the police
service itself that finally decides uh
what penalty should be imposed it's an
independent board run by a legally
qualified individual
and a lay member of the public plus a
senior police officer and it's that body
that decides whether somebody should or
shouldn't be
dismissed
for
what they've done
and as with
any crime
there is always a scale of seriousness
from
i won't call it trivial but from the
lesser end up to the most serious sexual
harassment up to the most serious
offenses
like
rape um
so
what would you refer to as the lesser
end of sexual offences
i'm sorry
what would you refer to as the lesser
end of sexual offences in your opinion
i would refer to something like a police
officer who has been to see
a relatively vulnerable woman and who
then calls
for her for no good policing reason uh
but simply because he
he wants to form a relationship with her
in my terms that would be falling below
the appropriate standard of behavior
but i don't think that in itself
would justify that officer being
dismissed
that could be terrifying for that woman
who has called a police officer when
she's at the most vulnerable
indeed it could be
and i'm not minimizing that all i'm
saying
is that there is always a spectrum of
seriousness in any offence whether it's
a police officer or any member of the
public
okay good to talk to you today thanks so
much indeed for joining us on the
program thank you